[Musica]
sono nata e cresciuta a pian del falco
una piccola località appenninica 1400
metri che magari qualcuno di voi conosce
sono cresciuta fino all'età della
scolarizzazione solo a contatto con i
miei genitori i miei nonni questo ha
fatto stecchino diventasse una bambina
timida chiusa introversa ma avevo un
fuoco dentro
avevo un fuoco io volevo diventare
qualcuno nello sci anche perché vivevo
sulla pista le piste da sci
volevo a tutti i costi farlo arrivarci
anche per valorizzarmi ma questo mio
sogno veniva deriso anche perché era
difficile rapportarsi con me visto il
mio carattere chiuso era difficile
capire cosa volevo anche da parte dei
miei allenatori e comunque anche
tecnicamente nei miei primi campionati
italiani non ho mai superato
l'ottantesima posizione la settantesima
l'anno dopo
ma non ero assolutamente vista come una
futura campionessa
fortunatamente io sono testarda e quel
fuoco è stato visto da due allenatori
che hanno creduto nella mia
testardaggine nel mio fuoco e mi hanno
accompagnato al mio sogno
a 16 anni sono entrata in squadra
nazionale e o e a21 ho fatto la mia
prima gara di coppa del mondo e ho
partecipato a più di 50 gare di coppa
del mondo
io però non ho nel mio palmares né
vittorie importanti in coppa del mondo e
ne medaglie importanti ma quello che
posso dire che ho delle conoscenze che
mi hanno cambiato la vita in questo
percorso mio di atleta mi hanno cambiato
la vita le mie amicizie allenatori che
hanno creduto in me che hanno fatto
venire fuori qualcosa di diverso tant'è
vero che se io penso alla bambina che
ero adolescente che ero chiusa incapace
di rapportarsi incapace di parlare con
gli altri sono qui allo storchi di
modena a parlare alte dix è un sogno che
si realizza grazie allo sci
nel 2001 finito la mia carriera ho
deciso di fare della mia passione la mia
professione
e così sono diventata maestra di sci
allenatrice istruttrice e come tutti
quelli che finiscono una cari ad atleta
ho cominciato ad allen mi sono
avvicinata al mondo degli sci club e mi
sono avvicinata al mondo dei bambini ho
allenato bambini adolescenti erano delle
spugne mi rivolgevo tantissimo a dare
tutto ciò che avevo imparato tutte le
mie emozioni tutte il mio trascorso lo
dava loro loro errori delle spugne ma
poi qualcosa è cambiato stia dentro di
macchie fuori di me
i genitori lo sci club voleva la
prestazione voleva la competizione
voleva il risultato volevano il podio la
medaglia
e i genitori non si rendevano conto che
accanto a loro la medaglia c'era già di
bambini stavano crescendo erano
indipendenti
e in più c'era un'altra cosa che mi
aveva rischio nato in una maniera
proprio che non era mia mi chiedevano di
fare gruppi diversi gruppi dove i più
forti con i più forti i più deboli coi
più deboli perché i deboli o quelli meno
scarpis cars rallentavano il lavoro dei
più forti
ma sta avessero pensato così per con me
io non sarei stata questa sera io non
sarei qua stasera se avessero pensato xi
con me e così mi sono distaccata da quel
mondo non era più il mio mondo lo avevo
già vissuto non lo era più ho deciso
così di fare solo la maestra di sci mi
sono messa però a creare dei gruppi
eterogenei nella giornata in una
giornata sola io volevo delle persone
con differenti livelli tecnici e tecnici
scusate differenti livelli tecnici vuol
dire che c'erano persone che si dovevano
preparare magari per la selezione da
maestra con un buon livello tecnico
padre e figlio che vogliono fare
un'esperienza diversa
dei classici scialpinisti che volevano
imparare la tecnica di discesa quindi
tutti obiettivi diversi e questo mi
stimolava tantissimo perché io dovevo
trovare delle soluzioni per ognuno di
loro
io nella stessa giornata dovevo trovare
delle soluzioni per tutte le esigenze
delle persone che venivano da me
ma la cosa ancora più bella è accaduta
dopo un avvenimento che ha cambiato la
vita un mio amico
silvio
che è qui tra il pubblico e lo ringrazio
di essere qui
ha avuto nexus anni fa e lo ricordo
ancora in un letto di ospedale proprio
qui nel modenese che era lì
completamente paralizzata la sua parte
sinistra del corpo e diceva ma io voglio
tornare a sciare lui era già maestro di
sci di fondo un appassionato di sci e
comunque uno sportivo proprio nel cuore
nell'anima e io non riuscivo a
capacitarmi come potesse pensare di
tornare a sciare non credevo fosse
possibile anche se lo rincorro leg lo
rincorre rincuorava ma lui che è più
testone di me
è stato veramente bravo determinato sia
avvicinata al mondo della disabilità e
s'è avvicinato al mondo dello sci per la
disabilità e dopo sei mesi era sugli sci
dopo un anno discendeva già dalle piste
importante se lo vedesse adesso fa
veramente impressione
ma silvio non si è fermato lì
silvio conoscendo il mondo della
disabilità ha conosciuto un sacco di
persone che avevano voglia di allenarsi
e in questo caso erano due persone in
style e rotelle e lui mi ha chiesto
babbi così mi chiamano perché non prendi
nel tuo gruppo questi due ragazzi che
sono i tagli a rotelle hanno bisogno di
fare un percorso diverso hanno bisogno
d'imparare share
ero terrorizzata perché io non conoscevo
la disabilità e quelle cose che non si
conoscono fanno paura e poi io non
sapevo come poter allenare non lo
conoscevo neanche a livello tecnico ma
non come fare ma da una parte stimolata
e dall'altra io non volevo deludere
silvio
e così ho fatto ho guardato che la mia
prossima uscita programmata era stubai
mi sono solo accertata della
accessibilità disturba è stupenda
località austriaca e ho portato loro nel
mio gruppo insieme a me
il primo giorno lo ricorderò tutta la
vita
ero agitata ero nervosa non sapevo come
fare in imbarazzo perché non sapevo come
essere con loro
non sapevo sa essere compassionevole
amorevole distaccata per aiutarli non
aiutarvi nel momento di un problema
e poi per fortuna accanto a me ha un
compagno che si occupa di disabilità da
un bel po di tempo perché ha fondato la
fondazione a bologna e al telefono mi ha
detto babbi tu devi essere te stessa
e così ho fatto il giorno dopo sono
tornata sulle piste dei rom sé stessa e
tutto è andato in modo normale non c'era
niente di anormale
l'unica cosa che cambiava che dovevo
trovare ancora delle differenze dei
diversi
differenti accorgimenti tecnici per loro
e quindi ero ancora più stimolata e poi
accaduto qualcosa nella mia testa del
mio cuore che ha cambiato ancora di più
il mio pensiero perché se io avevo
pensato che quello dovevo essere un
momento unico e io avrei dovuto trovare
uno spazio per allenare solo i disabili
ho capito che non doveva essere un
momento unico doveva essere sempre così
e adesso qui lasciatemi se differenze
rho abbastanza abili e disabili non mi
piace farlo soprattutto nel mio sport
perché nel mio sport sono tantissime
persone abili che sono un po disabili
tecnicamente e ci sono dei disabili che
tecnicamente fanno paura però ho bisogno
di farlo per differenziare il mio
pensiero per farvi capire dove vi porto
il mio pensiero
molte in molte giornate appenniniche
classic appenniniche con nebbia alcuni
venivano da me mi dice uno babbi
io oggi non riesco a fare e accanto a te
e figlia che è diventata cieca letta di
4 anni e per vivere ho dovuto sviluppare
delle capacità che non aveva per vivere
in questo caso per scene e ci ha pure in
neve fresca
quindi la parola io non riesco viene
cambiata e non so ancora come farlo e
allora siamo stimolati io a cercare di
capire come silvia lo sta facendo quale
percezione del suo corpo a che io posso
aiutare a far capire a quello che pensa
che non lo può fare
oppure semplicemente
quando alla mattina mi arriva un e mi
dice io ho sempre male questa gamba la
cosa è stata operata io non mi fido fra
la curva su questa gamma non mi fido e
di fianco a te la chicca modenese doc
tra l'altro
ogni su moncherino dove è stata amputata
proprio dopo un incidente sugli sci ma è
voluta tornare a sciare ma soffre della
sindrome dell'arto fantasma lei su
quella gamba che non ha ha sempre dolore
e ogni tanto la protesi che si infila
permettersi ashfar scarpe fare per
riuscire a far le crea delle vesciche
quindi ancora più dolore ma lei mentre
sciati dimostra che quando è in appoggio
sulla gamba che non sa fa la curva
migliore e quindi è fattibile oppure
quando la mattina ti capita di
sentirti incriccato tu vieni da medici
babbi ho dormito male ho la schiena
incriccata non so come riuscirò a fare
la lezione oggi ha anzi penso proprio
che non riuscirò a dare il massimo e di
fianco a te e beppe
che lui ha la tetraparesi spastica dalla
nascita ed incriccato io vi garantisco
che beta a tutto ma c'è una determinata
determinazione incredibile è che per
dimostrarti che lui può sciare nella tua
stessa pista nella tua stessa neve e
facendo anche il tuo stesso esercizio
lui per dimostrartelo anzi lui vuole
dimostrarcelo e lo fa tu se c'è la
schiena incriccata ma cosa ti importa
oppure semplicemente una giornata dove
non hai energia non hai voglia
ti senti stanco e magari anche poco
coraggio e di fianco the ai loro che
entrano dalla sedia a rotelle dentro
questo monosci e vi garantisco che
shared dentro un monosci ci vuole
coraggio perché l'ho provato e ci vuole
una grande forza fisica e allora e basta
ascoltare l'energia che trasmettono
basta mettersi una mano del cuore
quell'energia che non avevate quel
coraggio che non avevate un po vi arriva
e quindi questo io credo che passo dopo
passo voi in questo modo possiate
diventare meglio di meglio di prima e a
voi possiate arrivare al vostro meglio
anzi al vostro meglio che non è
relativamente meglio in assoluto è il
vostro
e quindi cosa sono venuta qui stasera
raccontarvi sono qua venuto a dirgli che
se io ricordo quella bambina alla delle
scienze ma anche pop a pochi anni fa
vedevo lo sci e lo sport solo come
competizione risultato portare il mio
fisico allo stremo per vedere dove
potevo arrivare io adesso lo sport lo
vivo anche in un'altra maniera che non è
l'assoluta non è l'assoluta delta però
anche in un'altra maniera
la vedo in crescita
interpersonale
l'aquila e la vedo in non stress la vedo
in in benessere fisico in benessere
fisico e psichico e quindi per avere
benessere fisico e politico e crescita
interpersonale ha bisogno di essere
fatto in un gruppo dove non ci sia
stress e quindi cosa vorrei lasciarvi
stasera vorrei dirvi questo fate sport
fate fare sport e ai vostri ragazzi ma
fatelo a volte anche in un gruppo
inclusivo dove ci siano differenze
tecniche differenze fisiche differenze
sociali
differenti anime con percorsi di vita
differenti che si incontrano
perché se a volte e spesso le differenze
vengono
pensate che siano delle barriere degli
ostacoli in questo modo qua io credo che
siano il valore aggiunto e vi dico
un'altra cosa che magari in questo
gruppo non si diventerà i campioni del
mondo non si diventerà i campioni
regionali provinciali della provincia
non si diventerà magari magari ma si
diventerà dopo un'esperienza del genere
migliori a 360 gradi grazie
[Applauso]